It's been a rough couple of days
for Donald Trump,
the inspiration for the hit
viral video "Annoying Orange,"
which I didn't know a lot of
people know, but there it is.
-(laughter) -A New York Times
investigation suggested
that he may not have paid taxes
since 1995,
when he lost almost
a billion dollars, with a "B."
It was also revealed
that he made an appearance
in a soft-core porn movie
right there. Uh...
(laughter and groaning)
The New York Attorney General
banned The Trump Foundation
from doing any fund-raising
in the state.
And in a late night tweet-storm,
he encouraged America
to watch a Miss Universe
winner's nonexistent sex tape.
Although-- I don't know--
I guess the phrase
"check out sex tape"
could be
an unrelated endorsement
for the 2014 Cameron Diaz,
Jason Segel romp, Sex Tape.
I don't know
why he was doing that otherwise.
Some analysts are calling it the
worst week in campaign history.
Worse even than when
William Howard Taft admitted
he had an adult baby fetish.
You guys remember that?
-You probably remember that,
right? -(laughter, groaning)
-Wow.
-"I've soiled my diapy."
(mutters) -(laughter)
But if there's one thing I know
about this jaundiced walrus
wrapped in cellophane,
it's that he never stops
topping himself.
So, comedians,
what is Trump gonna do this week
to make it even worse?
-Steve Agee. -Milk his tits
on live TV and try...
(laughter)
-And there's more.
-(laughter)
And try to sell it
as "stamina sauce."
-HARDWICK: All right. Yeah.
Points. -(laughter and groaning)
-I'll give you points for that.
Aw. -(applause)
Uh, Doug Benson.
I heard he's gonna
endorse himself.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: All right.
Points. He might. Brendon.
He's going to reveal
that stop-and-frisk
is how he met Melania.